العمده مدينه
قصف القوات الاخرانيه للمدينه اضف
ليوتونيف ان القصف الاوكرانيه اشتد مؤخرا
على المدينه واستهدف الاحياء السكنيه فيها
نظام
قطاع البنيه التحتيه والطاقه هي الاكبر من
نوعها ماذا في تفاصيل
نعم بالفعل سهام قبل قليل قياده الاركان
اعلنت اخر الاحصائيه لما جرى بالامس تقول
بانها اكثر من 90 صاروخا استهدف البنى
التحتيه في مناطق مختلفه في البلاد
استهدفت معظمها مصادر الطاقه الكهربائيه
والتدفئه وما الى ذلك تقول قياده الاركان
بانها تمكنت من اسقاط 77 صاروخا من هذه
الصواريخ من نوع كروز كما تقول بان هذا
الهجوم كان ايضا بواسطه الطائرات بدون
طيار قالت بانها اكثر من 10 وقالت بانها
اسقطت 10 منها من نوع شاهد 136 وايضا
اسقطت همم طائره مسيره اخرى صناعه روسيه
طبعا متعلمين شادي الصناعي ايرانيه وهمم
واضح طبعا انه على الرغم من ان نحن
نتحدثون من المنطقه الشرقيه سهام لم
تستهدف هذه المنطقه يعني يلبون التحتيه
والكهرباء لكن على الرغم من ذلك تاثر
التاثرا كبيرا لان هي اصلا
فيها منهاره في هذه المنطقه واعلن حاكم
دونيس بالامس بانه سيتم قطع الكهرباء وهو
ما حدث فعلا بعد تلك الضربات في كراماتوس
وفي همم سلافيونسكو في العديد من المدن
لتخفيف الضغط عن المدن الاخرى ولتخفيف
الضغط عن شبكه الكهرباء التي تاثرت بشكل
كبير في مدن كبيره كما تعلميه في كياب
وفيب وانيسا وميكو لايف ستوديفت كل هذه
المدن همم هذه الصواريخ طبعا واضح ان هناك
غضب واضح ان هناك يعني اقول سهام استفاده
ربما من هذا من هذه الوضعيه من جانب
الاوكرانيين في تفعيل هذه القضيه الحديث
طبعا يتحدث هنا عن همم
الذي وصف ما جرى بانه ارهاب روسي قال بانه
اذا لم يتمكن العالم من ايقاف هذه الغطرسه
لحد
الروس بدون عقاب فان هذا الارهاب على حد
وصفه السيد تجاوز حدود اوكرانيا ويصل الى
بلدان اخرى وهو ما حذرنا منه كما يقول
للسابقا وما حدث عندما سقطت بالصواريخ على
بولندا كما يقول الوضع هنا في المنطقه
الشرقيه ما زالت المعارك مستمره تعلمين
ربما هذه الجبهه الوحيده الان في عموم
اوكرانيا التي يمكن وصفها بالساخنه والتي
يوجد فيها حرب وجها لوجه على اعتبار ان
معظم مناطق اوكرانيا قد سحب منها الجيش
الاوكراني والان هناك نهر النيبر يفصل بين
القوات في خرسان بين القوات الاوكرانيه
والقوات الروسيه هنا تقول قياده الاركان
بانها تمكن خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه من صد- 9
محاولات روسيه للتقدم على محاور القتال في
دونيس لكنها تقول بانها وقعت خسائر كبيره
في صفوفها المهاجمين وتقول قياده الاركان
في بيان لها نقطه مهمه جدا همم سهام عندما
تتحدث عن ان هناك وحدات في الجيش الروسي
على محاور لجانس
ودونيس قد تم تدمير جزء كبير منها واشارت
هنا تحديدا الى الفرقه الاولى الاقليميه
في هنلفقه وتقول بان 50% من قدرتها
القتاليه ومن جنودها اما تتساقط بين قتيل
وجريح مما جعل القياده العسكري الروسيه
يعني تلغي هذه الفرقه وتوزع ما بقي من
جهودها على الفرق الاخرى تتحدث ايضا على
جبهه الكريمينا مصادر عسكريه اكدت لنا بان
هناك تقدم همم اوكراني ولو كان بسيطا على
هذه الجبهه تحدث عن جبهه الكريمينا
سباتهوفا تقول ايضا قياده الاركان عن هذه
المنطقه بانه هناك عمليات فرار من القوات
الروسيه في تلك المنطقه بسبب القصف
المستمر عليها منذ فتره وتقول بانه سبب
تاخرها في التقدم هناك هو الكميه الكبيره
من الالغام المزروعه في محو- في محيط هذه
الجبهه امام خطوط الموجهه
الى امين في نفسك امين هل هناك رد روسيه
على هذه الاتهامات من اوكرانيا وايضا
التفاصيل اكثر حول الروايه الروسيه لما
يحدث في بلده
النفويا كخوفكا
سهام الرد كان امس مباشره بعد ما همم جاء
في وسائل الاعلام بولنديه وحديث بعض
السياسيين سواء في بولندا او في بعض الدول
العضوه في حلف شمال الاطلسي همم بيان
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه كان واضحا قال بان
روسيا لم تستهدف ايت مواقع قرب الحدود
الاوكرانيه البولنديه وانما اظهرته وسائل
الاعلام بولنديه من صور من مكان هذا همم
الحديث همم على قتله بالسلاح الروسي في
اشاره الى ما يتم تداوله في الحقيقه سهام
حتى الان على ان حطام تلك الصواريخ
المفترضه همم يشبه الى حد كبير حطام
صواريخ اس 3 للدفاع الجوي وهنا همم يقول
الروس بان الفرضيه همم الارجح والاقرب الى
الواقع الى ان تكون تلك الصواريخ همم
صواريخ اوكرانيه سقطت بعد ان اخطات هدفها
همم باعتراض الصواريخ الروسيه لكن في
انتظار طبعا همم رد فعل اخر من قبل وزاره
الدفاع في بيانها اليوميه همم اليوم هناك
مناطق تشتعل فيها المواجهات العسكريه سواء
في الشارقه او حتى في مدينه نواكوفكا حيث
تتحدث السلطات المواليه لروسيا هناك عن
مقتل سته مدنيين وجرحه 20 اخرين خلال
يومين فقط من القصف الاوكراني التي تقول
تلك السلطات انه لا يتوقف على تلك المدينه
التي تعد الان ااه في الحقيقه تقريبا هي
معقل همم المواليد لروسيا في منطقه خرسون
على الضفه اليسرى من نهر النيبر بعد ان
انسحبت القوات الروسيه من الدفاع اليمنى
النهر هنا في دنياك القصف لا يتوقف من
الجانبين نسمع بين الفينه والاخرى قصفا
مدفعيا وايضا براجمات الصواريخ هناك تحرك
عسكري روسي وتركيز على جبهه افديفكا وعلى
او القرى التي همم تقع خلف مطار دونيسك
الدولي بعد الحديث عن السيطره على بلده
اوبيتنيا الان يتم تركيزها على بيربو
مايسكاي وفيديو فيما يبدو انه توجه سهام
من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه لاحكام طوقين
حول مدينه افديه ولكن قبل ذلك يسعون على
ما يبدو ومن خلال التصريحات العسكريه انهم
يحاولون قطعه طريق الامداد الرئيسي من ااه
عمقه الاراضي الاوكرانيه باتجاه مدينه
صعب جدا همم بعد سيطره القوات الاوكرانيه
على بلده مكيفكا وسعيها الان اللي همم
التقدم باتجاه الطريق الرابط
بيننايه همم لقطعه ذلك الطريق الامداد
الاستراتيجي الى ربما الاهم بالنسبه
للقوات الروسيه في مقاطعه لوغانس وايضا في
ذلك المحور وهو مثلث حدودي بين مقاطعه
دنيا اسكولوجانسكو ايضا خارج كيف الروس
كذلك يتحدثون عن تقدم في جبهه كورفكا
وايضا في جبهه باخموت بالرغم من ان قوات
فاجنر ومن خلال التصريحات الصادره عن
اجانب الروسي لربما تتقدم لكن ببطء تقدمها
لربما يقاس ببضع عشرات من الامطار يوميا
لصعوبه همم المواجهات في ذلك الموقع وايضا
وصل حديث عن دفع القوات الاوكرانيه بدعم
عسكري وايضا تعزيزات عسكري كبيره الى
مدينه اخرى شكرا
الذي كان معنا من كرامته